j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
second débat de ce sens public consacré
à la grande misère de la psychiatrie
française il y a trois semaines vous
vous en souvenez sûrement deux
soignantes du CHU de Reims était agressé
au couteau l'une d'elles Karen une
infirmière de 38 ans décédé peu après
leur agresseur c'était un homme connu
pour ses antécédents psychiatriques
qu'il avait même déjà été violent contre
le personnel de santé d'un ESAT avant de
débattre de l'état de la psychiatrie en
France je vous propose un reportage qui
illustre son manque de moyens avec
Mathias Arès on est au centre
hospitalier de s'intégrève près de
Grenoble
chaque matin lors de la distribution des
traitements les infirmiers du service
post-urgence du centre hospitalier
alpizaire et change quelques mots avec
les patients c'est un moment qui est
quand même assez charnière et assez
important parce que ça permet de faire
plein de choses informelles et une
évaluation informelle de l'état des
patients l'état clinique des patients de
l'évolution de soumise en son de des
traitements ce qu'ils ont comprennent et
toutes ces choses là ce service l'apex
accueille des personnes en souffrance
ayant connu des épisodes suicidaires de
dépression ou de crises émotionnelle
forte c'est vraiment un service
d'évaluation psychiatrique et
d'apaisement de la crise c'est vraiment
ça notre notre projet
et à l'issue du passage sur l'apex qui
peut durer cinq jours une semaine 15
jours on oriente on oriente la prise en
charge médicale donc soit une
sectorisation donc en hospitalisation
complète sur l'hôpital soit on décide
d'une d'une d'un retour à domicile et
avec une prise en charge soit en
ambulatoire libéral pendant leur séjour
les malades bénéficient d'un suivi
personnalisé d'un traitement médical
adapté et d'une surveillance accrue une
organisation 24 heures sur 24 qui
nécessitent de l'accordation entre les
équipes pour la cohérence de soins en
fait il est important que les soignants
puissent transmettre en fait ce qui
s'est passé pendant tout le temps où ils
étaient présents auprès des patients
seulement voilà ces dernières années
l'hôpital psychiatrique comme par tout
en France est en sous effectif sur
l'ensemble des sites c'est 25 postes de
médecins en équivalent en plein qui sont
à pourvoir ça crée des situations un peu
délicates par moments où notamment pour
les vacances en fait on est
souvent seul dans les unités où on
devrait y avoir un équivalent d'au moins
de temps et demi de temps plein et demi
de médecins en fait et pourtant la
direction l'assure il ne s'agit pas d'un
problème de moyens mais de recrutement
la France n'a pas formé suffisamment de
médecins dans les années passées
un changement de cap a été pris
néanmoins entre le changement de cap et
l'arrivée effective des médecins formés
qui pourront prendre des postes qui va
se passer quelques années et nous savons
que nous sommes dans le creux de la
vague encore pour quelques années ce qui
va nous conduire à devoir trouver de
nouvelles organisations de travail de
nouvelles façons de faire pour mettre en
adéquation les ressources que nous avons
avec les besoins que nous rencontrons
une demande de soin mentaux de plus en
plus importante et face à elle délit qui
continue de fermer
pour débattre sur l'état de la
psychiatrie en France j'accueille Marion
le Boyer bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de psychiatrie et
l'Université Paris Est Créteil
responsable du pôle de psychiatrie des
hôpitaux universitaires Henri Mondor
directrice de la Fondation fondamentale
et auteur de ce livre psychiatrie l'état
d'urgence publié chez Fayard Jean-Sol
bonsoir bienvenue sénateur LR de des
Pyrénées-Orientales et membre de la
commission des affaires sociales ici au
Sénat Frédéric bizard bonsoir bienvenue
économie spécialiste des questions de
protection sociale et de santé
professeur d'économie affilié à le SCPE
Europe et puis ce livre l'autonomie
solidaire en santé la seule réforme
possible libre publie aux éditions
Michalon Mathieu croissanto est resté à
mes côtés évidemment je vous propose de
démarrer du constat avec ce chiffre
donné par le ministère de la Santé une
personne sur 5 touchée chaque année par
un trouble psychique Marion le Boyer on
parle de quoi moi je pense à la
dépression évidemment principalement
est-ce que sont des chiffres globalement
stable qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire de ce de ce premier constat alors
c'est vrai que la fréquence de ces
maladies est extrêmement importante en
tout cas que c'est des maladies qui
diminuent pas très clairement
contrairement au cancer ou à d'autres
maladies sur lesquelles l'État a
beaucoup investi ces dernières années ça
regroupe comme vous venez de le dire des
maladies très différentes comme des
dépressions des troubles anxieux des
troubles psychotiques des troubles
bipolaires des troubles qu'on appelle
maintenant du neuro-développement
l'autisme infantile l'hyperactivité bref
des pathologies extrêmement diverses qui
explique ce chiffre très important ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est que l'impact du
covid considérablement augmenté le
nombre de nouveaux cas à la fois parce
qu'il y a eu toute une série de
situations extrêmement stressante et
extrêmement difficile mais aussi parce
que les personnes qui ont été infectées
sont plus à risque de développer des
troubles dépressifs des troubles anxieux
et des troubles cognitifs c'est le cas
de toutes les pandémies puisqu'en fait
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y a un lien
très important entre infection
inflammation et le déclenchement de
maladies mentales mais c'est vrai
quelque chose dont on parle pas
suffisamment et qui est pas connu de
l'ensemble des concepts de nos
concitoyens on en dira un mot je pense
de de l'effet de la crise covid j'en sol
est-ce que on peut dire que la
psychiatrie c'est le parent pauvre de
notre système de santé bon j'en suis
personnellement convaincu mais pour
personnellement je le découvre pas
cet état de fait ça fait des décennies
que les professionnels alertes qu'ils
soient médecins experts paramédicaux et
je n'ai pas du tout le sentiment
aujourd'hui que les choses en tout cas
étaient évoluées malgré quand même les
moyens injectés puisque c'est quand même
le premier pôle de dépenses équivaut
aujourd'hui à 109 milliards d'euros ou
un peu plus c'est quand même pas anodin
et 23 au 24 milliards prise en charge
par par l'Assurance Maladie
vous entendez je pense qu'il a manqué
une volonté politique affirmée un cap
et puis surtout famille politique aux
manettes je crois qu'elle était
effectivement le gouvernement en place
je pense que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
le débat et
ça n'est pas mon sens qu'une question de
moyens je pense que il y a des questions
orgues organisationnelles des questions
de management ce lien entre les hôpitaux
la médecine libérale nos généralistes et
puis à mon sens un travail en matière de
coopération et de coordination surtout
fallait bizarre il faut peut-être
appeler quelque chose les psychiatres
sont parmi les les médecins les moins
bien payés déjà ça c'est une un élément
de l'équation qu'il faut rappeler
oui de façon assez étonnante d'ailleurs
parce que c'est une spécialité
complexe les services aussi de services
de hospitalier subissent des réductions
de crédit régulièrement mais c'est pour
ça qu'il faut quand même rattacher cette
crise de la psychiatrie on viendra sur
l'aspect parentaux parce que on discuter
quand on regarde la
quantité de dépenses c'est pas le pas en
bourse c'est le premier poste de débence
mais c'est parce que il y a des besoins
absolument en colossaux donc mais on
peut pas dire que l'État n'investit pas
ce qu'il faut mais comme pour les autres
spécialités on a une régulation qui est
plutôt comptable que basée sur des
objectifs de santé publique je ne sais
pas s'il y a des objectifs bien établis
de santé publique en matière de santé
mentale j'en ai pas l'impression mais
oui on est encore dans un pilotage à
l'aveugle où on raisonne à partir d'un
budget comptable d'un PLFSS et puis au
cours de l'année on a des dépassements
dans d'autres services et c'est vrai que
les services de psychiatrie souvent qui
est d'ailleurs ne sont pas payés à la
T2A mais sur le but payer à la la
tarification à l'activité pardon qui est
souvent décrié vu comme étant à la
source de tous les mots mais là on voit
qu'il y a un budget global et en fait ça
ne change pas le fait que ce budget
global ne répond pas et n'est pas assis
sur une évaluation précise des besoins
et donc se retrouve très insuffisant
surtout d'ailleurs quand on les Crète au
cours de l'année donc c'est il faut le
lier quand même à la crise systémique
bien sûr évidemment alors vous allez-y
peut-être juste revenir sur l'histoire
du coup en fait c'est le premier poste
de dépenses mais parce qu'il y a une
énorme part dans ces 109 milliards qui
d'ailleurs maintenant sont de 160
milliards parce que les coûts continuent
à augmenter des coûts indirects donc là
par coup direct elle est en fait elle
est importante bien sûr parce que c'est
des maladies très fréquentes les coups
indirects c'est tout ce qui est lié au
fait que ces patients ils vont pas
travailler que les aidants et leurs
proches peuvent pas non plus travailler
que il y a toute une série de
conséquences indirectes liées à ces
maladies mentales qui font que c'est
vraiment le premier poste de dépenses de
toutes les maladies c'est aussi la
première propose de ce qu'on appelle les
Dali qui est le nombre de journées de
vie perdue à cause d'une pathologie mais
ça c'est pas spécifique à la France
c'est dans le monde entier ce qui est
spécifique à la France c'est peut-être
que effectivement comme vous venez de le
dire on navigue un petit peu à vue et au
lieu d'avoir des indicateurs
d'efficacité d'activités y compris des
réduction des coûts parce que si on
prenait en charge les patients plutôt de
façon plus spécialisée plus efficace
peut-être qu'on réduirait aussi ses
clients
aussi caché ces maladies qu'on ne
saurait voir parce que de la part de la
classe politique à part quelques élus
qui se sont emparés de ce sujet c'est
toujours un sujet que qu'on met de côté
d'une société se reconnaît à la façon
dont elle traite à la fois c'est fou et
ses prisonniers on le sait mais il y a
ce terme-là mais on sait on s'est
contenté ça fait quand même 20 ou 30 ans
qu'on est parmi les premiers
consommateurs mondiaux donc soviétique
ou d'antidépresseurs
je sais pas mais
ça fait ça fait quand même un sacré
nombre d'années que ce que ce débat là
il est il est en place qu'à chaque
campagne présidentielle vous avez des
tribunes de psychiatre qui a l'air sur
l'état de la psychiatrie en France à
chaque campagne des candidats disent oui
oui mais ça fait jamais partie des
priorités affichées par par les
exécutifs quel qu'il soit de toute de
toute couleur politique alors on vous
évoquait le la crise covid qui a aggravé
la situation en écoute cette professeur
en pédopsychiatrie Sylvie Tordjman qui
nous le détaille d'une certaine façon un
crise sanitaire est venu en effet
amplifier pour la plupart de ces jeunes
une situation de mal-être qui existait
d'ores et déjà mais qui arrive à tenir
il y a une fragilité minéralité mais
finalement ça s'exprimait pas ils
arrivaient à continuer donc leur vie un
peu comme d'habitude là la différence
c'est que à partir du moment où il y a
ce stress et cette anxiété anticipatoire
qui vient se sur Ajouter c'est un peu
comme un système qui est débordé et où
du coup cette fragilité va s'exprimer
avec une vulnérabilité aussi bien aux
troubles anxieux aux troubles dépressif
avec des maladies psychiques qui sont
encore tabou pour en parler je vous
propose de rejoindre en duplex Didier
Meyran qui est le fondateur du psychodon
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est l'Olympia du psychodon
ce soir concert pour sensibiliser
justement pour lever ses tabous dont on
parle autour des des maladies mentales
il y en a encore beaucoup
bonsoir oui il y a encore beaucoup de
tabous vous avez des experts sur le
plateau qui peuvent vous le confirmer et
puis il y a un traitement de l'actualité
qui est parfois caricatural et qui
contribue à stigmatiser des personnes
concernées par une maladie psychique ou
en situation de handicap mental elles ne
sont pas des criminelles d'une manière
aussi caricaturale que certains médias
veulent bien le dire et ça contribue à
amplifier la stigmatisation la mission
du psychodondre c'est de faire cause de
la santé mentale et nous le faisons avec
avec joie avec la musique avec les stars
avec la scène de l'Olympia parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours drôle
ce que nous vivons mais ce soir sur la
scène de l'Olympia il y a Christophe
Huel il y a Patrick Bruel il y a Louis
Bertignac il y a plein de chanteurs pour
que ensemble on passe une soirée dédiée
à la santé mentale et à la
destinatisation des personnes concernées
par une maladie psychique ça fait
combien d'années qu'il existe le
psychodon et est-ce que vous voyez quand
même les mentalités évoluent un petit
peu
c'est la cinquième édition du psychodon
ou oui ça évolue hier dans la plupart
des villes de France ont eu lieu les
marches ensemble pour la santé mentale
mais quand même une grande mobilisation
il y a aussi une prise de conscience des
pouvoirs publics qui s'élaborent le
dispositif mon parcours psy qui est loin
d'être parfait est une première amorce
pour que la consultation auprès des
psychologues soit la plus facilité
possible avec une forme de
conventionnement de remboursement c'est
pas encore en accès direct mais c'est un
vrai progrès c'est très contesté il y a
beaucoup pas faire mais c'est un premier
pas aujourd'hui on peut grâce aux
dispositif mon parcours psychique
d'ailleurs évolué change de nom
consulter des psychologues d'une façon
remboursée conventionnée pour une
première dizaine de séances il va
falloir beaucoup travailler pour
amplifier ces prises en charge et puis
il y a des besoins très importants mais
vous avez des experts pour le sur le
plateau pour la recherche pour l'hôpital
la prise en charge l'ambulatoire et puis
moi je pense beaucoup au logement agent
c'est quelque chose avec mon frère il
faut construire des masses des maisons
d'accueil spécialisées pour ça il y a
besoin d'argent et pour cela il faut
donner il faut donner aux psychodon il
faut donner aux associations qui mettent
en œuvre sur les territoires des projets
pour accueillir les personnes concernées
dernier mot parce que vous devez
repartir pour le voilà la préparation
évidemment de cette soirée donc je vous
garde pas plus longtemps mais vous
diriez quoi le manque de psy aujourd'hui
c'est la première des urgences pour vous
alors c'est vrai que là encore vous avez
des experts pour vous en parler la
psychiatrie la spécialité des
psychiatres c'est peut-être pas celle
qui est la plus attractive dans la
formation des médecins et puis on est
peut-être pas assez largement sous doté
en pédopsychiatre on a des psychologues
on a beaucoup de psychologues en France
mais le problème c'est que pour le
moment la nomenclature est pas tout à
fait précise l'accès au consultations
des psychologues et pas encore vraiment
complètement organisé que vous trouvez
une bonne modalité entre les CMP où il
faut recruter vous recrutez beaucoup de
psychologues dans les centres médicaux
psychologiques il faut donner aussi
accès pourquoi pas aux psychologue en
libéral pour que les personnes puissent
consulter dès les premiers troubles
psychiques et les experts que vous avez
sur le plateau vous le diront que plus
la prévention est active plus l'on
consulte tôt moins l'errance
thérapeutiques
se déploie et plus l'espérance de vie il
confort de vie et est important vous
savez que je dis toujours nous à
l'Olympia et sur nos chaînes de télé on
fait très simple on a une mission de
sensibilisation vulgarisation on dit
toujours tu as mal aux dents tu vas chez
le dentiste un petit peu mal il faut
faire soigner ta carie tu as un problème
de vue tu vas chez l'ophtalmologiste tu
te sens pas bien dans ta tête c'est
pareil il faut pas se poser de questions
il y a pas de ta bouche au consulter le
plus tôt sera le mieux merci beaucoup
Didier mean pour ces messages est bon
Olympia du psychodon ce soir
effectivement Jean-Sol le temps
d'attente pour pour avoir un rendez-vous
alors c'est vrai d'une manière générale
mais c'est particulièrement vrai je
crois pour les pédopsychiatres ça peut
aller jusqu'à 18 mois 2 ans on a on a vu
ça en préparant l'émission c'est cet
après-midi enfin il faut imaginer une
famille qui qui essaye d'avoir un
rendez-vous chez le pédopsychiatre avec
l'angoisse que ça représente d'avoir un
enfant qui a des trouble psychiques tout
à fait c'est la réalité madame le Boyer
le confirmant un certainement ça
n'existe pas en fait la problématique
n'est pas inhérente seulement au
pédopsychiatre mais il est vrai que
quand un enfant on a un enfant et un
jeune adolescent que que le que l'on
attend autant de temps pour avoir une
consonation en pédopsie psychiatrie
notamment ça effectivement pas normal
dans notre pays aujourd'hui au 21e
siècle c'est c'est clair d'autant que
l'on sait l'impact de ces de ces
consultations précoces dans la détection
des des symptômes et puis dans
l'accompagnement et le suivi en tout cas
de de ces jeunes adolescent bon j'en
avais j'avais débattu avec certains en
poste crise sanitaire puisque j'avais
participé à un rapport sur l'impact de
cette crise sanitaire notamment sur la
santé mentale de nos jeunes il y avait
des témoignages particulièrement à
figeants émouvant alors jusqu'à vous
dire en direct je vais envisager de me
suicider donc la problématique elle est
bien là comment vous expliquer on
reviendra au à l'impact finalement de du
retard c'est à dire que dans la prise en
charge des maladies psychiques mais
Marion le Boyer peut-être déjà le
constat du manque de de médecin comment
ça s'écrit pourquoi c'est pas plus
attractif en France alors c'est vrai que
c'est une spécificité tristement
française qui s'est considérablement
aggravé et qui continue à s'aggraver en
post période covid ou tout d'un coup
toute discipline confondue il y a eu un
effondrement de l'attrait qui avait pour
l'hôpital que ça soit les médecins que
ça soit les infirmières donc il y a un
manque aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la
psychiatrie
de psychiatre pour les postes de
praticiens hospitalier à l'hôpital les
chiffres je crois c'est assez inquiétant
puisqu'il y a 3600 postes de praticien
hospitalier en France et je crois qu'il
y en a 1600 qui sont vacances donc c'est
énorme et ça empêche les services de
fonctionner ça entraîne des fermetures
de lit parce que quand il y a plus de
médecins et plus d'infirmière on est
obligé de fermer des lits et donc ça
aggrave le cercle vicieux qui est que
les
urgences sont encombrées que la
précocité du diagnostic et de la prise
en charge dont on parlait tout à l'heure
elle peut plus être respectée et ça
entraîne une cascade de catastrophe donc
c'est vrai aujourd'hui que si je peux
dire un message sur ce plateau c'est que
l'attractivité il faut vraiment la
renforcer aujourd'hui si on prend
l'exemple de nos collègues canadiens la
psychiatrie la première discipline
choisie par les internes à Toronto la
première qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait au
Canada pour rendre ce métier ils ont
expliqué que la médecine était une
profession qui se féminisait et que
c'était probablement moins fatigant
physiquement d'être psychiatre que
d'être au bloc opératoire et
deuxièmement ils ont soutenu la
recherche ils ont expliqué
qu'aujourd'hui la vision la
représentation qu'on avait des maladies
mentales la compréhension de ces
maladies avait totalement changé et que
les années à venir étaient des années
extraordinaires pour le développement
d'une nouvelle picatrie et en fait en
France on n'arrive pas à expliquer ça
alors que on vient d'obtenir trois
énormes programmes dans le cadre de
France 2030 qui sont des vrais succès et
qui montrent bien que malgré toutes les
difficultés qu'on vient d'évoquer
aujourd'hui la recherche en psychiatrie
française elle est extrêmement efficace
donc ça veut dire des forces 2030 plants
d'investissement et donc c'était sur la
base de projets il y a trois projets à
la psychiatrie qui ont obtenu par un
jury international donc on a eu un
programme qui s'appelle PEPR programme
projet en psychiatrie précision qui a
été financé en juillet dernier avec un
budget de 80 millions alors c'est pour
faire de la recherche c'est pas ça qui
va faire fonctionner mieux à l'hôpital
ça d'avoir pas tous les détails
excusez-moi mais c'est un levier
d'attractivité c'est ça exactement
c'est que la psychiatrie en train se
transformer et que les cinq ou les dix
années à venir ça va ça devrait être
quelque chose une révolution sur le plan
la prise en charge des patients
moi je pense que le niveau de la
psychiatrie dans les grands centres
d'excellence en France reste encore du
d'une qualité exceptionnelle et donc ça
c'est quand même un atout parce que sont
des ressources longues ça met des
décennies pour construire ce qu'on a là
alors celle certes ça s'effrite je suis
pas sûr que le principal problème soit
là le problème il est que cette
spécialité elle est quand même devenue
une spécialité profondément ambulatoire
là où il faut aller prévenir le risque
le plus tôt possible et là on n'est pas
à l'hôpital et c'est pas à l'hôpital que
ça se passe c'est pas seulement à
l'hôpital que ça se joue quoi ce dégrade
en termes d'attractivité parce que tout
l'hôpital se dégrade en termes
d'attractivité on l'a déjà dit beaucoup
ici l'hôpital est encore dans un moule
totalement inadapté aux aspirations
individuelles des nouvelles génération
même les postes les plus les plus
prestigieux de chef de clinique ne
trouvent pas preneur dans beaucoup de
spécialités bon donc on pourrait refaire
le le débat donc évidemment la
psychiatrie en souvenez mais j'ai le
sentiment mais je parle sous le contrôle
de Madame le boitier que que là où il y
a la déficience la plus forte c'est dans
l'approche ambulatoire dans la gestion
de l'ambulatoire qui en effet ne trouve
plus beaucoup preneur pour des raisons
en partie comme une c'est que au sein de
la communauté médicale il y a une perte
d'attractivité de la spécialité
proprement dit mais là où c'est une
spécialité relativement un sécure à
l'hôpital ce qu'on a pas parlé beaucoup
des problèmes de sécurité mais c'est un
vrai sujet
et des conditions d'environnement à
l'hôpital qui sont dégradées c'est un
sécure en ville et mal payé donc si vous
voulez ça fait beaucoup et clairement là
il y a pas beaucoup de signaux qui sont
envoyés vous savez que c'est en ville
c'est de ces mais d'ailleurs c'est pas
que que libéral j'entends souvent
libérale en ville mais les CMP sont sur
le mode salarié et les CMP ont aussi
perdu un vrai problème notre activité
donc là on voit bien que le salaire est
un des éléments libéral qui est
important et ça on devrait être capable
de le résoudre donc vous avez le haut de
la pyramide où vous avez cet effet
recherche qui est quand même plutôt dans
un état satisfaisant en France même si
on manque d'investissement dans cette
recherche médicale pas d'autres mais je
pense que le problème gravissime il est
véritablement dans trance de basculer
cette spécialité vers une force
qui permette de d'éviter que beaucoup de
gens aillent à l'hôpital et là où ils en
ont pas besoin de dépister très tôt
alors votre avis là-dessus du jour donne
la parole ah on a absolument besoin
d'améliorer la prévention le diagnostic
précoce parce que c'est des maladies
comme les autres et que comme les autres
plutôt on fait diagnostic et plutôt ont
mis en place des stratégies
thérapeutiques meilleur elle pronostic
mais ça ça peut prendre combien d'années
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un déficit de
alors pas seulement on l'a compris pas
seulement dans cette spécialité mais on
a un déficit de candidat donc ça peut
prendre combien de temps pour rattraper
le retard si puisqu'on est dans un talon
on est dans le temps long et on a vu ces
dernières années partir un certain
nombre de jeunes médecins ou un médecin
vers la ville ils vont ils viennent plus
à l'hôpital que ça soit sur les CMP ou
que ça soit sur les postes
d'hospitalisation ou d'autres structures
qu'on a ils sont plus là enfin il y en a
il y a vraiment énormément de de postes
vacants ils vont beaucoup plus vers une
médecine psychiatrique libérale en ville
et il faut déjà commencer par réouvrir
le nombre d'interne et d'interne en
psychiatrie qui continuent à diminuer
par exemple en Île-de-France le nombre
de postes ouverts continuent à diminuer
donc il y a vraiment si on veut reformer
des médecins sur le temps long il faut
commencer par ouvrir ce goulot notre
angle alors justement on va parler des
des leviers que le que l'État que le
gouvernement
peuvent élever qu'ils peuvent activer
une critique pour démarrer à propos de
l'action du gouvernement celle de la
sénatrice socialiste des Côtes d'Armor
Annie Le wérou c'était en séance ici au
Sénat en novembre dernier
les troubles
de psy maladies devant les cancers la
souffrance psychique conduit à 200 000
tentatives de suicide en France chaque
année et 9000 issus fatales soit un taux
de suicide parmi les plus élevé d'Europe
nombreux décès sont évitables Agnès
Buzyn ministre de la Santé reconnaissait
en 2017 je cite l'abandon de la
psychiatrie 5 ans après rien n'a changé
des professionnels qui alertent on l'a
dit ici depuis plusieurs années les
pouvoirs publics sur cette crise de la
psychiatrie en réponse l'exécutif et on
va en parler tout de suite avec Steve
Jourdain a lancé l'organisation
rebonsoir Steve l'organisation d'assise
de la santé mentale et de la psychiatrie
c'était en septembre 2021 oui des
assises annoncés par Emmanuel Macron en
janvier de la même année c'est-à-dire en
pleine crise covid faire un état des
lieux de la situation et se projeter sur
l'avenir d'un secteur à bout de souffle
bon Thomas l’annonce de ses assises
n'avaient pas vraiment bouleversé les
professionnels qui estimaient que la
situation était largement documentée ils
avaient raison un rapport sénatorial de
2017 écrivait la chose suivante peut de
sujets ont fait l'objet d'autant de
rapports publics au fil des dernières
décennies que la psychiatrie fin de
citation depuis les années 80 on compte
en effet pas moins d'une douzaine de
rapports produits sur la question peu
d'enthousiasme vous l'avez dit à
l'annonce de ces organisations de ces
assises elles ont finalement débouché
sur quoi alors sur plusieurs
décisions en clôture des réunions qui
étaient organisées sur deux jours le
chef de l'État à détailler une trentaine
de mesures parmi elles le remboursement
des consultations de psychologues pour
tous à condition qu'elle soit prescrites
par un médecin il a aussi promis la
création de postes dans les centres
médicaux psychologiques écoutez
au cœur de la psychiatrie de secteur que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure nous allons
aussi renforcer les centres
médico-psychologiques qui sont cette
élément clé
historiquement
caractéristiques du modèle français pour
conforter leur rôle de coordination des
soins et de la trajectoire des patients
en créant dès que possible des postes
supplémentaires qui réduiront les délais
d'attente qui sont parfois devenus
insupportables au total 800 postes
supplémentaires ont été annoncés pour
ces centres qui connaissent une
explosion de leur demande depuis une
vingtaine d'années l'objectif de ces
créations raccourcir les délais
d'attentes pour avoir un rendez-vous
aujourd'hui dans certains endroits en
France vous devez patienter en moyenne
18 mois pour une consultation Thomas et
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres mesures
annoncées d'autres mesures dans les
tuyaux non selon le gouvernement et
malgré les difficultés leur n'est pas
aux nouvelles annonces écoutez
ces difficultés sont reconnues depuis
plus d'un an sous l'égide du président
de la République les assises de la
psychiatrie se sont tenus il y a un an
on parle de quoi on parle de 15 500
psychiatres on parle de 600
établissements c'est pas rien ça nous
met quand même quoi qu'on dise dans la
moyenne européenne il faut que tout ça
fonctionne mieux ensemble
ces psychiatres ces personnels de
psychiatrie font un travail remarquable
je me suis engagé à mieux reconnaître la
pénibilité spécifique de ce travail il
faut bien sûr le reconnaître voilà et
dans le même temps les fermetures de lit
continuent à Rennes par exemple hôpital
Guillaume Régnier vient d'annoncer la
fermeture de 20 lits en psychiatrie
adulte la décision prendra effet à la
fin du mois de merci Steve pour ces
informations Jean-Sol moi quand
j'entends cette dernière information on
continue de fermer des lits dans
certains services de psychiatrie comment
c'est possible après le constat qu'on
vient de faire et que vous connaissez
vous dites vous-même c'est un constat
qu'on a fait depuis longtemps notamment
que c'est
inadmissible c'est inondendable comment
pouvons nous dire aujourd'hui dans la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons que nous ferons des lits avec
ces délais d'attente avec
ce manque à mon avis de de d'ambition de
volonté notamment en matière de
prévention de pouvoir se donner les
moyens enfin pour moi c'est que c'est
quelque chose d'intolérable que je me
mets à la place à une de ces jeunes qui
ont besoin de soins de consultation
encore une fois de suivi
d'accompagnement et ça demande du temps
ça demande de la mobilisation et une
énergie particulière de nos médecins
psychiatre mais aussi de nos personnels
paramédicaux et je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faudra essayer de renvoyer
cette image qui apparaît assez souvent
devant nous en disant ben écoutez les
maladies et les maladies physiques
considérée comme quelque part noble sont
traités et puis de l'autre côté on a
toutes ces du patients qui sont atteints
de de
pathologies mentale et ils n'ont pas
fait ce choix là et qu'on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui de voir délaisser d'être
délaissé sur le bord du chômage c'est ce
que je pense en tout cas
je vais vous poser la même question
parce que c'est quand on dit on manque
de psychiatre il y a 18 mois d'attente
etc et on continue de fermer les lits
donc c'est ce que vous ayez tout à
l'heure on est on est dans tant qu'on
n'aura pas changé
l'approche du système lui-même quoi
c'est c'est comme ça depuis des années
parce qu'il faut voir comment est
gouverner ce système de santé qui
définit le budget de la santé est-ce que
c'est un budget défini par le ministère
de la Santé sur des bases de besoins de
santé publique ou est-ce que c'est un
budget qui est défini par Bercy sur des
objectifs purement comptables bon c'est
la deuxième voie c'est une réalité c'est
pas juste pas sarcastique ou pas c'est
comme ça que c'est fait le
la première ministre a demandé de faire
5% de réduction de dépenses à l'ensemble
des ministères donc
merci à comme objectif de faire 5%, là
où c'est le moins visible quelque part
et notamment c'est le le piège de cette
enveloppe globale c'est qu'au temps sur
la tarification à l'activité vous pouvez
pas arrêter les actes on va pas fermer
les lits parce que on veut moins d'acte
faut pas non plus pousser trop en
revanche une enveloppe globale sur
lequel on peut enlever 5 %, ça c'est
c'est assez peu visible oui donc moi je
veux bien que on brosse dans le sens du
poil les professionnels à chaque fois en
disant qu'ils font un travail
extraordinaire mais mais la cause du
problème elle est dans cette gouvernance
comptable et technocratique si l'hôpital
est devenu peu attractif en psychiatrie
comme ailleurs il y a des causes
profondes que l'on connaît et très
honnêtement je vois pas très bien le
gouvernement et les différents partis
politiques prennent ce sujet prendre ce
sujet pardon vraiment un bras le corps
et donc je crains que et la psychiatrie
est évidemment quelque chose de très
stratégique parce que c'est visible à
l'échelle de la société tout le monde à
quelqu'un de concerné parce que c'est
la plus importante mais mais c'est
malheureusement un fait généraliser dans
le système j'en solde un élément de
réponse là-dessus parce qu'effectivement
voilà on est tant qu'on n'aura pas
abandonner cette logique comptable on
continuera de faire ce débat c'est un
peu l'impression que j'ai quoi je ne
sais pas si on continue à faire ce débat
mais si vous voulez face à ses besoins
ses besoins croissants c'est retors
quand même dans la prise en charge qui
qui quelque part génère à mon sens une
perte de chance quand même pour les
patients atteints de de de ces
pathologies
je pense que en regard si vous voulez
regarde ces besoins croissants fermer
des lits aujourd'hui ne me parle ne me
paraît pas être quelque chose de
responsable sortir de cette de cette
logique
médico-économique comptable oui mais
comment et puis
une chose enfin que que l'on évoque peu
aussi c'est ce travail un équipe
pluridisciplinaire aujourd'hui nous
parlions d'attractivité tout à l'heure
j'ai reçu moi dans le département j'ai
en tout cas initié weekend découverte il
y a à peu près une quinzaine de jours où
il y avait 60 jeunes étudiants en
médecine et pratiquement tous souhaite
ce travail en équipe pluridisciplinaire
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ne faut pas
opposer les hôpitaux publics le privé
nos cliniques la médecine libérale et
nos généraliste c'est ensemble je pense
que nous arriverons à trouver en tout
cas des des réponses qui rentrent dans
le sens le prise en charge de qualité et
surtout sécuritaire
de programmation sanitaire à 5 ans c'est
du régalien la santé faite comme on fait
pour la défense et laisser redonner du
pouvoir sur un plan budgétaire au chef
de service si on prend l'hôpital ce
qu'il avait avant vous avec lui il a une
capacité à estimer ses besoins et
laisser les acteurs faire de la
pluridisciplinarité il y a pas besoin
que le politique s'occupe de ça les
acteurs le savent et le front très bien
alors il y a une question que évidemment
beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs se
posent est-ce que ça veut dire
appartement où il y a un manque de
d'encadrement de prise en charge ce qui
veut dire qu'il y a des fous dangereux
en liberté et évidemment nous on a on
est parti sur ce débat après la mort de
cette infirmière à Reims on l'a rappelé
Marion Boyer son agresseur il faisait
l'objet de soins psychiatrique depuis
1985 il avait déjà attaqué des soignants
c'était dans un ESAT en 2017 comment
vous est-ce que ces drames permettent au
moins une forme de prise de conscience
qu'on organise des débats comme celui-là
qui est comment vous réagissez vous face
à ça alors c'est une situation tragique
la mort de quelqu'un en train de
travailler c'est et puis évidemment
épouvantable mais ce qui est aussi
épouvantable c'est la façon dont la
presse ou les médias le traitent en
faisant un coup de projecteur sur des
événements qui sont finalement
extrêmement rares on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il y a moins de 10 homicides par an
qui sont commis par les personnes qui
dans le jugement alors que à l'inverse
les personnes qui sont atteintes de
maladies mentales sont 10 fois plus
victimes d'actes criminels que la
population générale donc évidemment ça
nous permet d'être sur ce plateau ce
soir ça nous met en même temps on parle
pas du reste et on donne l'impression à
la fois aux patients à leur famille aux
personnels soignants que c'est des
maladies qui entraînent ce type d'acte
alors qu'ils sont extrêmement rares et
je pense que ça c'est vraiment important
de le dire mais c'est pour ça que je
vous ai posé cette question je savais
que vous vous teniez à dire ça mais
est-ce qu'on peut pas quand même faire
le lien entre un drame comme celui-là et
le manque de moyens pour prendre en
charge un malade psychiatrique mais bien
sûr mais il y a d'autres moyens de le
démontrer et de le dire il y a plein
d'autres retard par exemple on a
beaucoup parlé du du retard de prise en
charge de ces pathologies mais ce qu'il
faut aussi savoir c'est que ces patients
ils ont 15 ans d'espérance de vie perdue
non pas seulement à cause des suicide
mais à cause des pathologies médicales
associées qui sont beaucoup plus
fréquentes chez ces patients là et qui
sont pas prises en charge donc il y a on
parlait de pluridisciplinarité là aussi
un retard de diagnostic et un retard de
connaissances il y a un retard
d'information et donc un retard de
diagnostic donc c'est l'ensemble du
système qu'il faut repenser et
l'information je pense que vraiment
l'information pour réduire cette
stigmatisation améliorer la précocité du
diagnostic améliorer la prise en charge
de ces pathologies qui sont des
pathologies de l'individu dans sa
globalité et pas juste des pathologies
du cerveau aujourd'hui on a appris
énormément de choses sur le plan de la
compréhension de ces pathologies et en
particulier les causes le lien entre le
terrain génétique et les facteurs de
risque environnementaux et pourquoi il y
a beaucoup plus de pathologies médicales
qui sont pas prises en charge
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que la
recherche continue d'avancer ce que vous
lui-même vous avez été
voilà j'arrive pas à trouver le mot mais
bon vous avez remporté un prix en la
matière il y a quelques années et on ça
aussi ça passe un peu sous les radars
médiatiques mais totalement récompensé
totalement cherché non non totalement
c'est que en fait ça aussi ça
permettrait de changer l'image de ces
pathologies en expliquant au grand
public les causes de ces pathologies le
fait qu'on arrive à les diagnostiquer à
condition qu'on n'ait pas peur d'aller
voir le psychiatre comme
on le disait tout à l'heure et que si on
comprend mieux les causes si on comprend
mieux les mécanismes on a moins peur
d'aller voir un médecin fallait bizarre
on l'a dit mais on se pose la question
des politiques publiques de la capacité
à
atténuer cette crise elle coûte
particulièrement cher à la société
française c'est-à-dire que le fait que
des patients souffrant de troubles
psychiatriques ou manteau soit pas pris
en charge ils vont finir année après
année par coûter de plus en plus cher
quoi c'est ça mais là il y a un vrai
c'est probablement responsable en tant
qu'économiste mais il y a un vrai
problème d'éducation de la population et
des pouvoirs publics sur la relation
entre la santé le système de santé la
bonne santé et le développement
économique s'il y a bien des leviers
aujourd'hui avec une productivité qui
relativement faible aujourd'hui de
développer notre l'économie c'est bien
par l'amélioration de l'état de santé on
l'a vu avec le système de retraite il
faut c'est par le taux d'activité si on
a une croissance aujourd'hui c'est pas
lié à la productivité c'est lié au fait
que vous avez plus de monde sur le
marché du travail mais si vous regardez
toutes les personnes qui souffrent de il
a dit psychiatrique ou de troubles
mentaux ces personnes là sont soit
exclues du marché du travail ou
partiellement exclus du marché du
travail donc on voit bien que c'est
probablement un des secteurs sur lequel
les dépenses de santé ont un retour sur
investissement les plus élevés à
l'échelle de la société donc ça mais
vous voyez qu'on dit ça on dit bah voilà
l'économiste dit ça non mais ça devrait
être un moteur dans la priorisation des
dépenses de santé puisque il y a des ce
qu'on appelle des externalités très
fortes en matière et ça on a du mal à
faire raisonner les pouvoirs publics
dans ce sens allez-y ouais si je peux me
permettre c'est la notion qu'on a
développé qui s'appelle le capital
cérébral qui est que quand on a des
sociétés dont les cerveaux fonctionnent
bien ils sont à la fois plus productifs
ils coûtent moins cher sur le plan de
toute une série d'éléments qu'on a déjà
décrit et ils sont plus capables de
d'être résilient quand il y a une
épidémie quand il y a une catastrophe
donc lutter améliorer très précocement
et très efficacement la prise en charge
des maladies du cerveau c'est faire des
économies considérables pour un pays
Jean-Sol ce serait de l'argent un public
bien dépensé bon je pense que c'est de
l'argent public dépenser et qui
répondent surtout à des besoins et
encore en faudrait-il tenir ses
promesses et puis et puis évaluer le
dispositif tout à l'heure votre votre
collègue parlez là de renforcer les CMP
à hauteur de 800 postes on va on va pas
trouver 800 800 personnes du jour au
lendemain il va falloir les former ça va
demander du temps
je suis je suis dubitatif c'est une
bonne mesure mais combien de temps ça va
nous prendre et le seul renforcement des
CMP ne va pas résoudre toutes les
problématiques auxquelles sont
confrontées aujourd'hui nos médecins
psychiatres et nos personnels
paramédicaux on a parlé de formation je
pense qu'il faut multiplier aussi nos
efforts madame le Boyer en matière de de
formation notamment en direction des non
seulement des médecins des médecins
généralistes des médecins libéraux et de
nos personnels paramédicaux pour ceux
qui nous rejoint CMP centre
médico-psychologie les mesures à retard
sont beaucoup plus urgentes en fait que
les mesures à effet immédiates à chaque
fois j'entends oui mais le problème
c'est qu'on a déjà de médecins ça a été
dit qui fuit la spécialité et qu'on a
une spécialité qui est moins attractive
donc vous voyez qu'il y a pas besoin de
technologies pour comprendre que
malheureusement on va vers des des mois
et des années beaucoup beaucoup plus
dramatiques que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc inversons déjà ça en ayant une
politique de santé mentale à la hauteur
de ce qu'attendent les professionnels et
la communauté et ça enfin franchement on
a on a tous les moyens pour l'avoir on
va pas tout régler dans l'année qui
vient mais si vous inversez cette
tendance là vous êtes quand même sur une
meilleure tendance que si on continue à
dans ce dans cette voie là et le manque
de personnel soignant dans les services
de psychiatrie évidemment à des
conséquences aussi dans la prise en
charge des malades écoutez ce témoignage
un infirmier psychiatrique qui
manifestait à à Paris s'appelle Lionel
le bourg
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans un
manque de moyens la psychiatrie c'est un
boulot dans lequel on doit pouvoir
consacrer du temps au patient et pour ça
il faut qu'on soit en nombre moi je peux
vous dire ça ça va faire 30 ans que je
bosse j'ai jamais vu autant de
contentions ces derniers mois que j'ai
pu en voir dans les années précédentes
avant on était en nombre on pouvait
faire des choses avec les patients quand
il y avait besoin de calmer les
angoisses on les accompagner aujourd'hui
on peut plus faire tout ça ce qu'on nous
demande c'est de la rentabilité de la
rentabilité là il y en a ras-le-bol
alors c'est un témoignage qui date de
quelques années qui date de 2019 Marion
le Boyer est-ce que ça s'est amélioré
est-ce qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
soignants qui n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de d'attacher quand on parle de
contention d'attacher les malades ça
c'est pas du tout amélioré et c'est un
des éléments qui fait fuir le personnel
qui soit médical ou paramédical de
l'hôpital parce que il y a pas assez de
monde et que donc la qualité des soins
qu'ils offrent aux patients et pas du
tout à la hauteur de ce qu'il souhaite
faire et de l'ordre de leur ambitions
qui sont bien entendu de bien soigner et
donc effectivement les hospitalisations
sont contraintes les contentions elles
augmentent par manque de personnel et
par manque de moyens mais ça veut dire
qu'on applique des techniques je sais
pas quel terme employé qu'on ne devrait
plus appliquer alors tout ce qu'on fait
on doit l'applique parce qu'on a le
droit de le faire mais c'est quand même
un symptôme de manque de moyens de
retard de diagnostic de d'aussi de
gravité de ces pathologies parce que les
patients qui arrivent à l'hôpital ils
arrivent trop tard souvent avec beaucoup
d'autres pathologies psychiatriques ou
addictives associées dans des contextes
souvent très grande violence bien sûr
c'est pas la totalité des patients mais
c'est un nombre important de patients et
c'est sûr que le manque de moyens le
manque d'effectif fait entraîne des
situations qui sont celles qui viennent
d'être décrites
intéressant cette ce que dit l'infirmier
parce que il y a ce sentiment qui qui
est un sentiment dévoyé mais qu'en fait
l'hôpital est devenu machine Afrique une
machine à rentabiliser ce qui est pas le
cas là l'état public on a jamais il y a
pas d'actionnaire derrière l'hôpital
public pas plus aujourd'hui qui a 30 ans
mais cette approche comptable fait qu'on
essaye toujours de faire des économies
par ci par là et qu'en fait on ne répond
pas aux besoins et qu'on est capable de
en effet fermer des lits pour assurer ce
cet objectif comptable qui est pas fixé
par les soignants évidemment qui fixent
en haut et donc c'est comme la
tarification à l'activité c'est à dire
que les soignants ont vraiment
l'impression qu'on est devenu sur une
espèce de machine à faire de l'argent
complètement déconnecté de la santé
publique évidemment quand on est à
l'hôpital public ça devrait être vrai
partout mais quand on est à l'hôpital
public c'est d'autant plus inacceptable
et décourageant et qui font que les gens
arrêtent ça fait partie enfin je pense
moi en tout cas de de cette paire
d'attractivité c'est que des gens sont à
l'hôpital public parce que
sens public parce que c'est le sens
auquel il donne à leur activité et je
crois que cette gouvernance là elle est
elle est elle est pour eux elle est pour
eux totalement antinomique avec ce sens
Jean-Sol un dernier mot c'est c'est vrai
dans
la France dans tous les territoires il y
a des territoires forcément encore moins
bien lotiques que les autres on observe
nous observons une hétérogénéité
territoriale c'est ça c'est nous
l'observons tous les jours certains
départements sont mieux dotés mieux
l'outil que que d'autres c'est une
évidence
merci beaucoup merci à tous Marion le
voyage rappelle le titre de votre livre
psychiatrie l'état d'urgence qui est
publié chez Faya fallait bizarre
l'autonomie solidaire en santé la seule
réforme possible aux éditions Michalon
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité vous pouvez nous retrouver
ainsi que tous les programmes de Public
Sénat sur la plateforme Public Sénat
point FR et puis notez que demain Oriane
mansigny dans la matinale reçoit comme a
été politique Nicolas Mayer Rossignol le
premier secrétaire délégué du Parti
socialiste et maire de la ville de Rouen
bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]